now let's go back in time it's 1974
there is the gallery somewhere in the
world and there is a young girl aged 23
standing in the middle of the space in a
front of her is a table on the table
there are 76 objects for pleasure and
for the pain some of objects are glass
of water a coat a shoe a rose but also
the knife the razor blade the hammer and
the pistol with one bullet there is
instructions which says I'm an object
you can use everything on the table on
me I'm taking all responsibility even
killing me and the time is six hours the
beginning of this performance was easy
people who give me glass of water to
drink
they give me rose but after very soon
there was a man take the scissor and cut
my clothes and then they will take the
turns of the rose and stick in my
stomach somebody take a razor blade and
cut my neck and drink the blood and I
still have the scarf the women will tell
the man what to do and the man didn't
rape me because it was just a normal
opening and it was the art public and
there with their wives they carry me
around and put on the table and put a
knife between my legs
and somebody took the pistol and put the
bullet and put against my tempo
and another person take the pistol and
they start fight and after six hours was
finished I start walking towards the
public I was a mess
I was half-naked I was full of blood and
tears was running in my face and
everybody escaped they just run away
they could not confront myself with
myself as a normal human being and then
what happened is I went to the hotel it
was a 2:00 in the morning and I look
myself in the mirror and I had a piece
of gray hair all right please take your
blindfolds welcome to the performance
ward
first of all let's explain what is the
performance so many artists so many
different explanations but my
explanation of performance is very
simple performance is mental and
physical construction that performer
make in a specific time in the space in
the front of audience and then energy
dialog happen the audience and the
performer make the piece together and
the difference between performance and
theater is huge in the theater the knife
is not a knife and the blood is just
ketchup in the performance the blood is
the material and the razor blade or
knife is the tool this is all about
being there in the real time and you
can't rehearse performance because you
can't do many of these times things
twice ever which is very important the
performance is you know all the human
beings are always afraid force very
simple things we are afraid of suffering
we afraid of pain
we are afraid the mortality so what I'm
doing I'm staging this kind of fears in
the front of audience I'm using your
energy and with this energy I can go and
push my body as far as I can and then I
liberate myself from these fears and I'm
you Mira if I can do this for myself you
can do for you after Belgrade where I
was born I went to Amsterdam and you
know I've been doing performances since
last 40 years and here I met who I and
he was the person I actually fall in
love and we made for 12 years
performance together you know the knife
and pistols and the bullets exchanged
into love and trust so to do this kind
of work you have to trust person
completely because this arrow is
pointing my heart so hard the beating
and adrenaline is rushing a song is
about trust is about total trust to
another human being our relationship it
was 12 years and we work on so many
subjects about male and female energy
and as every relation comes to an end
Aras went - we didn't make phone calls
like a normal human being do and say you
know this is over we walk Great Wall of
China to say goodbye I start from the
yellow sea and he start from the Gobi
Desert we walk each of us three months
two and a half thousand kilometer it was
the mountains it was difficult
it was climbing it was ruins it was you
know going through the 12 Chinese
promises this was before China was open
in 87 and we succeed to meet in the
middle to say goodbye and then our
relation stopped and now I completely
change the way how I see the public and
one of our important piece I made in
those days it was Balkan Baroque and
this was the time of the Balkan Wars and
I wanted to create some very strong
charismatic image something that can sir
for any war any time because Balkan war
now is finished but it's always some war
somewhere
so here I'm washing two and a half
thousand bake big cow bloody bones you
can't wash the blood
you never can wash shame of the wars so
I'm washing these six hours six days and
warm succumbing of these bones and
becoming possible in unbearable smell
but then something stays in the memory I
want to show you the one who really
changed my life and this was the
performance in Norman which just
recently I made this performance when I
say to the curator and we're just going
to sit at the chair and they will be
empty chair in the front and anybody
from the public can come and sit as long
as want the curator said to me that's
ridiculous you know this is New York
this trade will be empty nobody have
time to sit in the front of you but I
see three months and I said every day
eight hours the opening of the museum
and ten hours on Friday when the museum
is open ten hours and I never move and I
remove the table and I feel sitting and
this change everything
this performance maybe 10 or 15 years
ago but nothing happened but in need of
people to actually experience something
different the public was not anymore the
group relation was one-to-one I was
watching these people they would come
and sit in front of me but they have to
wait for an hours hours and hours to get
to this position and finally they sit
and what happen they are observed other
people they're photographed they're
filmed by the camera they observed by me
and they are nowhere to escape except in
themselves
and that makes a difference there was so
much pain and loneliness there's so much
incredible things when you look in
somebody else eyes because in the gaze
without total stranger that you never
even say one word everything happened
and I understood when I stood up from
that chair after three months I'm not
the same anymore and I understood that I
have a very strong mission that I have
to communicate this experience to
everybody and this is how for me was
born the idea
to have institute of immaterial
performing arts because thinking about a
materiality performance is time-based
art it's not like a painting
you have the painting on the wall in X
days their performance if you are
missing it you you only have the memory
or the story of somebody else telling
you but you actually miss all thing so
you have to be there and in my point if
you talk about in material art music is
the highest absolutely highest art of
all because it's the most immature and
then after this is performance and then
everything else is my subjective way
this Institute is going to happen in
Hudson upstate New York and we are
trying to build with REM koolhaas idea
and it's very simple if you want to get
experience you have to give me your time
you have to sign the contract before you
enter the building that you will spend
their full six hours you have to give me
your word of honor
it's something so old-fashioned but if
you don't respect you own word of honor
and you leave before that's not my
problem
but it is six hours the experience and
then after you finish you get
certificate accomplishment
so get home and frame it if you want
this is a rotational whole the public I
mean and the first thing you have to do
is to be dressed lab coats is this
importance of stepping from being just a
viewer into experimenter and then you go
to the here to lockers and you put your
watch your iPhone your iPad your
computer and everything digital
electronic and you are getting free time
for yourself for the first time because
Tecna is not in wrong with technology
it's wrong our approach to technology we
are losing every time we have ourselves
this is the Institute to actually give
you back this time so what you do here
first you start slow walking you start
slowing down you're going back to
simplicity after slowing walking you're
going to learn how to drink water very
simple drinking water for maybe half an
hour after this you go into the magnet
chamber which you're going to create in
some magnet streams on your body then
after this you go to Crystal chamber
after crystal chamber you go to I guess
after I guess in chamber you go to
chamber that you are lying down so it's
a three basic position of human body
sitting standing lying and slow walking
and then the sound chamber and then
after you saw all this and prepare
yourself mentally and physically then
you are ready to see something long
duration like like in a material art can
be music can be opera can be theater
piece can be filmed can be video dance
you go to the long duration of chairs
because now you're comfortable in the
long duration of chairs your transport
it to the big place where you're going
to see the the work and if you fall in
sleep which is very possible because
being long day you go into the
transporter to the parking lot and you
know sleeping is very important in
sleeping you're still receiving art so
in the parking lot you stay for a
certain amount of time and then after
this you just you know go back to see
more of the things you like to see or go
home with own certificate so this
institute is right now is virtual right
now I am just making my Institute in
Brazil that is going to be in Australia
then it's coming to here to to Canada
everywhere and this is to experience
kind of simple method how you go back to
simplicity in your own life coyote rice
will be another thing you know if you
can't rice you can make life too how to
can't rise six hours it's incredibly
important you know you go through this
all range of being bored being angry
being completely frustrated not can't
finish the amount of rice you're
counting and then this unbelievable
amount of peace you're getting with
satisfying work is finish out how to
stand in the desert or having the sound
isolated situation that you have
headphones that you don't hear anything
and you're just there together without
sound with the people experiencing
silence just the simple silence we are
always doing things we like in our life
and this is why we're not changing we do
duty see life it's just nothing happened
if you always do things the same way
but we're in my method is to do things
I'm afraid of the things I fear the
things I don't know to go to territory
that nobody ever been and then also to
include the failure I think failure is
important because if you go if
experiment you can fail if you don't go
into that area and you don't fail you
are actually repeating yourself over and
over again and I think that the human
being right now need a change and the
only change to be made it's a personal
level change you have to make the change
on yourself because the only way to
change consciousness and to change the
world around us is to start with
yourself it's so easy to criticize how
it's different the things in the world
and they're not right and this the
governments are corrupted and is hungry
in the world and is and the end of the
wars and killing but what we do on the
personal level what is our contribution
resulting can you turn to your neighbor
the one you don't know and look at them
to four minutes in the eyes right now
I'm asking two minutes of your time it's
so little breathe slowly
don't try to blink don't be
self-conscious be relaxed it just look
complete stranger in your eyes in his
eyes
thank you for trusting me thank you
thank you so much